who will win the 2014 Super Bowl many
people use statistics fantasy football
algorithms Moneyball styles sabermetric
calculations or just plain old
superstition to determine the winner of
this big event but we say the answers
can be found in all sorts of hidden
clues and connections in the movies of
the last year get ready to have your
mind blow the two competing teams are
Denver Broncos and the Seattle Seahawks
this year worldwide the highest-grossing
movie was Iron Man 3 at over a billion
dollars Don Cheadle from Iron Man 3 grew
up in Denver Colorado home of the
Broncos in Iron Man 3 Don Cheadle plays
the iron patriot the New England
Patriots I played football team that won
the Super Bowl in 2001 2003 and 2004 Tom
Brady of the New England Patriots is
married to Gisele Bundchen who used to
date wolf of wallstreet stars Leonardo
Leonardo DiCaprio grew up in Los Angeles
who also grew up in Los Angeles Michael
Bay his new transformers 4 age of
extinction first promo will debut during
the Superbowl Michael Bay was born on
February 17 1965 in Los Angeles the
first Super Bowl happened in Los Angeles
on January 15 1967
that's 697 days later the square root of
this number is 26.4 that's the age of
Zac Efron who's in neighbors and that
awkward moment Zac Efron made his
stardom in Disney Channel's high school
musical Disney made frozen the fourth
biggest movie of 2013 which 2013
animated movie made more than frozen
Despicable Me 2 takes the character
names GRU and minions and rearrange them
you get minus hours district 12 in The
Hunger Games is the district
- Jennifer Lawrence who plays Katniss
Everdeen is an American hustle of Amy
Adams Amy Adams plays Lois Lane in Man
of Steel which is about Superman
Bill Gates was in a documentary titled
Waiting for Superman
Bill Gates was the co-founder of
Microsoft with business magnate and
wealthy investor Paul Allen and Paul
Allen owns the Seattle Seahawks our
highly sophisticated movie calculations
estimate that the Seattle Seahawks will
win the Superbowl click on the posters
to watch clips and check back after the
Superbowl to see if our prediction came
true this video does not represent a
comprehensive statement of the actual
outcome of the NFL's Super Bowl winner
movie clips is not responsible for any
money lost in gambling and/or injuries
sustained during the super capers